okay so this is little dude um you're
not wearing a Finn and Jake's shirt no
took you this long to notice okay two
episodes of 1v log true I I make up for
it though cuz I'm wearing the exact same
shirt that I wore last week so really
yeah I think so I just so yeah so this
is um
Finn and Jake find this little pool they
want us more around and make a whirlpool
out which like doesn't that bring back
memories
oh yeah like hasn't every little kid
tried to do that it's like just a tiny
little thing they're like yeah I'm done
yeah I want they show how slow they're
going yeah be good so it's you're always
like it's gonna be massive but we're all
gonna get surrounded no big ever happens
um and so Finn takes his hand off they
follow the continuity and that his head
still shaved or it's growing back very
slowly and the head touches this flower
comes to life and turns out the flower
was part of this guy who was filled with
bad magic and the thing is evil and
anything it eats it turns to poop right
away but it looks like anything else so
that sucked and eventually goes and he
tries to you know possess other people
and just start destroying things and
they meet up with the guy with the
flower head says every time I think of
my dad and I do you know I think of this
evil magic and I don't know what to do
and Finn and Jake say what'd you think
of your mother already gets really happy
thinking about his mother brings all
these other things to life that are
happy and just wanna hug people and then
he does the same thing with Finn's hat
and Finn's hats like hey what's this
Jake's like it's live and then they're
like oh we gotta get a new hat they're
like let's kill a bear
evil they're evil bear so it sounds like
we found out what Finn's hat is like a
maybe a polar bear or something that
that's my guess which never occurred to
me honestly of all the I don't know why
of all the animals that never occurred
to me but it's actually like the most
logical especially considering we've
seen the bear that brown bear yeah and I
guess
yeah and even we put the hat on to be
the other thing right he have the little
bad mass right a fin yeah so yeah
something it is kind of funny about this
episode this episode is totally
serviceable I mean it's like nothing
wrong with it or bad or anything but
watching it did make me realize how much
when I watch one of these episodes now I
either want to see something really
extreme strange and we're like nothing
I've ever seen before really out there
it's gonna keep surprising me or I want
something that really connects to the
story and how emotional I can get and
revealing new surprises and stuff like
that so when just an OK episode comes
along I answer like I find I had sort of
less tolerance for ah I don't know that
a fair thing or not because like I watch
this I like this is fine it's not bad or
annoying me but you know okay can we
house Marceline doing with the whole Ice
King thing you know like house you know
is the Lich still roaming around is he
gonna give the rent somehow or you know
how's he dealing with you know his hero
skin being worn died by someone else
it's like all this stuff's are like but
I guess we're stuck with this um I don't
know about being too picky you know cuz
that like an episode of like the last
one is so strange and so bizarre you
know and the extra the life you honestly
have just been so out there crazy and so
unexpected that one I like I said a
totally standard episode this comes with
lots or like yeah so I don't know what
are your thoughts I think your
expectations are just too high and
that's sort of what I'm thinking
honestly it's like good this is totally
serviceable there's nothing wrong with
this episode but it's like I think it
has raised my expectations so much of
just like okay the bet your time Wow me
you know and it's I it's probably not a
good thing
um but yeah it is funny I guess that's
the sign of a good show and I when the
okay episodes come it's like oh you know
okay but it's not an episode
ya know I liked this episode I thought
this is a lot of fun considering I have
seen all the way up into the most recent
one going back and rewatching him I can
because no honestly when I first watched
through I was like okay yeah this is a
fine episode where's a really good one
okay this is a fine episode where it's a
really good one you know like I was the
same way honestly yeah but now being
able to kind of like go back and
re-watch it it's like I don't know I
really liked a little dude it was fun
there are some bizarre strange touches
in a Dana Snyder who I love his voice
acting that's shake Master Shake Todd
from code monkeys gazpacho from chowder
he's been in Soul the Moon Man he's done
a couple voices I'm here a dozen a few
times yeah I know how many I'm trying to
think is any time they've had a guest on
it's always been like one voice and then
they'll bring him back to through that
voice a member I think he's all I guess
where he's done like a couple voices
he's done this in at least one more that
I Can Has killing me excitement remember
exactly who did the voice for but yeah
he's been on here at least one more time
oh he was uh the Train he was the Train
that's what it was yeah remember the
father the fighting the farm oh yes yes
yes that's right the Train yeah I
thought you was something else too
wasn't he may have been but yeah it is a
very distinct voice when you hear him um
I love that guy though it's it well
somebody cuz I think they're saying in
the home movies commentary like you know
some people can't get into his voice and
they were saying they love it cuz they
say just ask the ask yourself the
question why would anybody say the
things the way he's saying it he puts
all the accents in the strangest places
and the voice you know the way he
enunciates is very you know like he'll
do this or a weird deliveries I guess he
did do it too much in this one but yeah
but yeah no I
I dig his moisture I can see how some
can find annoying but it's like I dig it
I think it's pretty funny um I love the
design of little dude I thought it was
just really cute
I loved how he like ate the sausages
and everyone's like and this is like oh
okay
I'm Finn picks up 600 poo now he's like
what it's like oh yeah I guess it is
boob better answer the one thing I
really why I love seen BMO has their
mother look like you know like getting
fins but ha BMO you're wearing the apron
everything hey I thought you kept better
company so yeah like that I really
enjoyed I loved what he was bringing
things like good things to life yeah
yeah like told me what a hug he's like
hug him into submission but my favorite
was of course well the candy person gets
attacked by little dude also he gets
huge and beefy why because he gains the
relative strength of the hat I have yet
we all gain the strength the natural
strength of the heft it's like what and
they still keeps it after he leaves he's
like all right but then he touches just
pants which also gets possessed so it's
like poor guy I mean these is being
tossed around but I love what he touches
Finn's pajamas when the pajamas come up
and he's like get so and get this kid
some clothes but what I was expecting
initially was the arms and the legs to
be the arms and the legs what I loved is
the arms have extra arms which are you
guys and the legs legs yeah you're right
you're right like that's just kind of I
love that and it's funny as hell there's
there's one miss joke opportunity I
thought maybe they were gonna do it was
when the guy was climbing the roof and
he said someone's on the roofing it's
like oh it's precise King again you know
he knows that we know he sleeps here
sometimes or something like that
I thought later me by the end of the
episode like they were gonna show the
Ice King still up there sleeping like
you know that guy you know something
they're gonna tie back into that but
never did but yeah so I'm it oh yeah I
mean I guess it's it's by no means bad I
mean there's nothing wrong with it
I like it's a total
serviceable episode um I think I'm just
getting spoiled that could be part of it
honestly what I also find very strange
is Dina Schneider a lot of his
characters I have like parental issues
and this one at sea has daddy issues but
Oh gazpacho and Todd both have mother
issues and it's he tends to play
characters that have parental issues huh
and when he's Master Shake Master Shake
is a terrible father so it's kind of all
just has something for bad parents weird
maybe that's like his guy like will not
play part unless somehow tie it in to
bad parent that's actually possible be
very specific like okay we're just
throwing a joke where you're a bad
parent yes so watch it so right I liked
this episode little do the school I'm
just thinking about giving that guy call
now and just being like hey let's film
something where your bad parent at he'll
agree okay if you do can I please be
there